kidnap John girls and kept him chained
to give blood blood for her to bathe in
him drink and she bit them everywhere no
and then she pushed why hide pokers into
their faces and when he parted her lips
to scream she shoved the flaming route
up into their mouths
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we're back once again for episode 53
countess Elizabeth Bathory yes this was
a request was it Veronica - Veronica
requested I don't know I don't remember
I can't remember but somebody requested
oh boy that's when we said we would do
it and I was like man I need to think
about that this is like a really great
topic it's a good topic I have looked
into this in a long time
I read some books on it it's a good
topic because there's still like a lot
of controversy about her that will
probably never be resolved yes a lot of
the original records from the time do
not exist anymore yeah that's the
problem with countess Bathory's
separating fact from fiction a lot of
its legendary but I don't think all of
it is the story yeah all right let's do
our shout outs and take care of
housecleaning here okay you guys seem to
be enjoying the movie reviews that yeah
I'm putting up lot of fun they are a lot
of fun for us to do so we really like
that you guys are enjoying I think as of
this recording I think we have four I
think we just put up legend of Hell
house and actually the next one we're
gonna do this was mine yeah we're gonna
do you wanna say no okay he's not gonna
say it's gonna be a surprise yeah and
let's see what else I think probably
everybody knows by now but audio podcast
should be up on iTunes now I'll put the
new link in the description like I
usually do if you still found it cuz it
still seems like a couple people are
like where is it and all this other kind
of stuff it's there someplace you know
if you look on the YouTube in the
YouTube description I usually put links
at the bottom where the blog is where
the iTunes feed is hasn't changed it's
just downloaded from a different place
that's all um let's see what else also
that 13 o'clock in minutes channel is
still up there the last one I put up was
creepy twins I think I'm usually trying
to do one of those a week or one every
two weeks because like I said they're
they're a lot more labor intensive than
the movie reviews are so that's why I've
been getting more movie reviews up
quicker than the other videos cuz the
other videos take like yeah and I'm
still getting asked to do other shows
you know yeah on the strength of that
yeah when they put that up will tell you
guys yes that's gonna be a fun show
because it's it's not really on a topic
so I can imagine that that's how that's
gonna go down that rabbit hole yeah so
that our I'm sure that our our and also
don't forget that we have a patreon at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast
I'll put a link in the description I
have been putting some extra stuff up
there I put a other day I put up a
review of extraordinary tales that
animated Edgar Allan Poe anthology movie
so if you want to go read that then go
give us a buck or five bucks or whatever
and then you can read all the extra
stuff and see listen to all our extra
audio and all that other kind of stuff
that's on there it's super fun and don't
forget to subscribe to 13 o'clock in
minutes yeah subscribe to 13 o'clock in
minutes laughs the Pensacola that's a
cool little channel that we have going I
did say something about that oh you did
yeah see this is why you have to listen
what we're recording because then you
keep repeating what I said I already
said it just goes in one ear out the
other
it's a girl talk seriously you guys we
have a lot of male listeners why why are
dudes like that like this guy it's kind
of like you're not accomplishing this
kind of lulls you kind of you know into
a certain is it a used to like women
like singing unis like that's a nice way
to put it it's like really we just don't
give a [ __ ] what are your six that just
reduces the heart rate anyway that's
enough of that
oh and spooky Empire we usually
mentioned that that's October 27th 28th
29th we are actually doing this sick and
twisted panel on Friday night so that
should be fun I have to decide on what
structure we're gonna do on it we want
to do more like audience interaction oh
don't forget our patreon yeah I said
that's you see yeah
I'm swayed you get the Elizabeth thanks
a lot okay I think that's all the all
the Reds and stuff oh I also go check
out my blog goddess of hellfire I put
some new reviews up on there
I reviewed actually two Middle Eastern
horror films Baskin and under the shadow
yes she was telling both which are
actually really good like I had heard a
lot of good reviews of him and so I said
well I'll just turn it into a double
feature so I watched him yesterday and
reviewed I'm like wow they were
excellent I think I like I mean I liked
them both they were totally different
Baskin was very it's very torture poorni
at the end but it's like it's surrealist
it's actually really cool it reminded me
like kind of like a David Lynch Dario
Argento torture porn yeah it was like
that and then the other one was kind of
like the babadook
but in Iran you know what I mean that
was kind of right it was like a creepy
ghost story but yeah they were both
really good so I recommend them and I
wrote a big long thing about him
yesterday so if you want to go read some
more movie reviews then he over it ahead
there's all kinds of our reviews on
there and I think that's probably all of
our usual gabbing at the beginning right
yeah it's good we got that out so now
we're gonna talk about Elizabeth báthory
yeah so what have you dug up about this
Jenny well it's true what is okay now I
think Elizabeth báthory I mean nowadays
she's probably not quite as famous as
like Vlad the Impaler but she's a
similar kind of figure and I think
particularly in the Gothic subculture
she's very well known and the
death-metal said things like that she's
very well known because of and she's
actually listed in no less an authority
than the Guinness Book of World Records
as the world's most prolific female
serial killer
if if what they say is true but even if
well even if the most conservative
estimates archery oh then she still is
okay now I have heard everything I think
the the figure that gets thrown around
the most is six hundred and fifty girls
right do I think she killed six hundred
and fifty girls
I don't know right the most conservative
estimate I've seen actually the official
tally I think is eighty but I have seen
estimates as low as 35 as Louis
that's still way more than most male
serial killers nowadays manage access to
people right now the problem with
Elizabeth báthory and like I said there
have been so I mean there's so much
media that's based on this bands named
after her their songs I'm not sure I
haven't I haven't watched American
Horror Story I know I should spank
myself but wasn't the season that had
Lady Gaga on it what she was a vampire
and I think she was supposed to be based
on countess Bathory at least partially
that's easy
yeah that's what I heard anyway and
there have been a bunch of movies my
personal favorite oh there was a hammer
one called the countess Dracula with
anger pit that was very good but
actually my favorite one is daughters of
darkness that's actually my favorite one
it's good it's not set back then it's
kind of set in the seven 60's or 70's or
whatever the movie was made but it's a
really cool movie that's kind of based
on the countess Bathory legend the
problem with countess Bathory is a
little bit the same problem as vlad the
impaler although i think that there's
actually more information extent about
vlad the impaler like i don't know if a
lot of the records about them were
destroyed even though a similar legend
sprung up about him later on
the problem with countess Bathory is
that after she died or so they say it
became illegal to talk about her because
she wanted they wanted her to be erased
from history yeah so they destroyed a
lot of records about her now some still
survive but not many yeah she was an
embarrassment to the royal family and so
the I mean you're right so that's kind
of where we're at so I think in the
absence of any solid information about
what she had actually done I do feel
like a lot of Legends probably sprung up
but like I said in a way I kind of feel
like in this situation where there's
smoke there's fire you know what I mean
even if she didn't do everything that
people attribute to her she still did a
lot of bad [ __ ] it seems like another I
think another important difference that
we have to point out is that vlad the
impaler or vlad tepes was actually then
that a national hero of law so it's yeah
there's still statues of him all over
the
he wasn't really considered a bad guy
more like a badass yeah it was fighting
the Turks and he would use one of those
guys that would try to win by any means
necessary and including using terror
tactics and a lot of what was said about
him you know sitting around dining as
people were being impaled in the context
of the time and in the context of the
other little national struggle that they
were in that would have actually been
probably seen as a virtue in other words
this dude is such a badass that he can
sit there and eat while he's watching
his enemies destroyed which probably
would have given a lot of his his people
would probably have a lot of confidence
if it actually happened maybe that
didn't happen right that might've just
been positive propaganda that he put out
war propaganda yeah that's positive
property oh yeah during the time during
those times hell yeah what mattered was
how how much of a badass you were he was
on the front lines right you know
fighting the Turks you're talking about
you know this is Renaissance era it
still had a lot of a Middle Ages and you
know medieval mentality and those people
this is something that would straight
out of Mad Max so you can't really judge
it by modern standards you got but he
was a hero but Elizabeth báthory this is
not a heroic figure at all they're
clearly describing a serial killer so
much yeah and that which was kind of
explain why I think there's less
information about her more legend
because I think they did try to erase
her from history yeah same way they
tried to erase you know Egyptian
pharaohs at certain times like I cannot
make sure I erase him from history it's
interesting to me though that I don't
know I guess because vlad the impaler
was usually seen as doing things against
their enemies you know that made him a
heroic figure
whereas Elizabeth báthory won she was a
woman to the fact that she wasn't so
much targeting their enemies as she was
just targeting her own servants so she
has not ever seen in their heroic light
I don't think never I know sometimes
sometimes you know people will point out
that Prince Vlad was nailing boyars hats
to their and today yeah or their shoes
to their head
and uh executing people for minor
thievery or for petty thievery but you
have to understand you know the boyars
were basically kind of like sacks and
merchants that were sapping the national
strength of Lakia and Malak es seems to
have kind of declined into lawlessness
so his domestic policy seemed to be one
of kind of like reconstruction well that
that would that means you know getting
rid of internal enemies even though the
boyars were kind of basically foreign
internal enemies and re-establishing law
and order and I think that just all kind
of added to his mojo that he was a
badass in domestic policy and he was a
badass abroad so Elizabeth báthory you
have to understand when she was born she
was born in 1560 she was born into
pretty much one of the wealthiest most
powerful families in the area
I mean her family had been running [ __ ]
in this area for about 300 years when
she was born the way she was raised she
was actually she was very very educated
so it wasn't a kind of thing where oh
she's just a girl you know we don't need
to send her to school we don't need she
know she was obviously very intelligent
they taught her many languages and
things of that nature she was married
off when she was 15 which wasn't unusual
at the time and when she married her
husband's name was French Nadezhda name
and he was actually later known as the
Black Knight and he had some kind of
similar qualities to Vlad the Impaler he
went to the frontlines and fought the
Turks there were legends about him that
he would cut off people's heads and play
kickball with them and things of that
nature so he was not just a super nice
guy either now he was only 19 or 20 when
he married her now even though it was an
arranged marriage by all accounts they
did seem to really dig each other like
because in a way they were both kind of
psychotic and so I guess they they kind
of got along on that wavelength but when
they married their combined wealth made
them actually richer than the king of
Hungary they had like ten castles they
presided over like seventeen villages I
mean they were just like ridiculously
wealthy and powerful
at first it said that her husband also
was a real strict disciplinarian with
their servants as Countess báthory was
so the legend goes that not that she
wasn't kind of a psycho from the
beginning but that her and the husband
kind of enjoyed torturing their servant
girls and then there was kind of some
stories that her husband some taught her
some tips and stuff like that for
torturing people and then those were
true or like I said okay well here's the
thing and that's probably not really a
productive question to ask because at
this point yeah like I said so much
records have been lost so it's right
it's there's really no telling right
there's no telling what's true or not
I'm just saying this is what a lot of
the different things about her say that
she kind of got tips from her husband
and that her husband was also really
strict as she was now it should be said
that in this time period and among the
nobility it was not unusual to beat the
[ __ ] out of your servants or even
torture them if they did something wrong
even if it was something minor no one
would have really thought much of it
that they were just beating the crap out
of these people wasn't a big deal
because to the nobility I mean when you
have that much money and servants are
coming from all these villages you own
and are essentially serfs they're pretty
much they come with the land you own
them you can do whatever you want with
them they're just they're disposable
they're expendable so it wouldn't have
been strange for them to beat the [ __ ]
out of their servants and things like
that yeah and of the nobility was
basically they were the law of the land
they were judge jury and executioner
yeah yeah you could kill servants with
impunity and no one would say boo at you
right I mean what are they gonna do
right rise within your authority yeah
what are they gonna do it's like what
are they gonna move somewhere else they
didn't have any money you know you were
kind of by the short and curlies really
you know what if you were a serf and you
lived in there and on their land there
was nothing you could do about it think
gangsters basically yeah that's pretty
much what anyway they're kind of Mad Max
gangsters yeah now her husband was gone
a great deal because he was a warrior he
usually out fighting against the ottoman
turks and things like that so she was
left alone a lot now one of the things
that I think a lot of apologists for her
like to point out that it's like well
you know she was obviously a very
powerful and intelligent woman she ran
all his [ __ ] while he was gone which
like I said seventeen villages ten
castles she did have her [ __ ] together
you know no one's saying she was a dummy
no one was saying anything like that you
know the fact that a woman was writing
all this kind of stuff yeah that's
admirable for that time in place now it
seems like all the real bad [ __ ] there
there had been rumors circulating about
not so much just like oh don't go don't
work for the bathroom she actually kept
her name when she got married because
she was a slightly higher social status
to her husband so she didn't change her
name to his so you know it was just kind
of a thing around the village she's like
well you know it's kind of an honor to
work in the castle because that's like
the big thing that everybody was
shooting for but a lot of nothing else
around there yeah there was probably
nothing else around but I think
sometimes like the peasants of the
things were kind of like oh I wish I
didn't have to send my girls to work
there because I'll get beat up and stuff
like that so I think there was a little
bit of that but like I said there wasn't
wasn't like you had a lot of choice like
old man I'll just quit good working
Donald you know what I mean it wasn't
anything like that there wasn't really
anywhere else to go now the real bad
[ __ ] doesn't seem to have started until
after her husband died now a cat's very
some people said he died in battle most
accounts say he died of a long illness
which is not really specified they just
said he started losing the strength in
his legs and thing though when he died
that would make her went in her 40s
around the time she was about now he was
only 48 so she was in her forties yeah
he died in 1604 now rumors had started
to circulate about her a little bit
before that like I said mostly that they
were kind of hard-asses and that maybe
things were going a little bit over the
top
yeah but now once her husband died then
it appears that all the stops came out
because after that rumors really started
ramping up that she was essentially
taking in girls from the village but it
was getting
to the point where girls were
disappearing girls were complaining that
they had been whipped they had been
bitten she would sometimes some of the
stories about her she would so people's
mouths shut and talking too much you
know she would do things like strip
girls naked get them all wet and then
throw them outside and the fries and
then watch that keep throwing water on
them until they froze to that covering
them with honey and putting them outside
and letting ants and wasps and stuff
like sting them it started getting
around that she was just doing stuff to
be sadistic yeah now I've also remember
hearing stories that she had some kind
of finishing school for girls at this
stage it was just servants okay like I
said in later years a lot of stories
came out about her like she would keep
girls in cages she would like stab him
with a spear and stuff like that you
know it was a lot of sexual stuff like
she would do like stick [ __ ] up their
vaginas and then stuff like that one
cheesecloth either watch our house the
sad thing about the bathroom case is
that had she felt like I said if she was
actually doing all this horrible [ __ ]
that because like I said rumors about it
were circulating for quite a long time
before anything really got done about it
now if she had just kept doing this
horrible [ __ ] to servant girls nothing
would happen do probably nothing was
within their power to do that now okay
there is one I believe that this letter
still exists like I said I've read
several accounts of this I watched
several documentaries about it and stuff
like that and you know even though the
information is kind of like one says
this one says that whatever I do believe
that there is a letter that still exists
that was written by the head of a
monastery that was across from one of
her castles because she had several the
person that wrote this letter was
complaining because they said this
reaming from her castle was so loud that
the monks basically had to like bang
their pots and stuff on the walls like
to drown out the noise this is a pretty
important piece of evidence right this
is one of the few pieces of evidence
that still still survives right yeah
this letter yeah so we do know that
there were witnesses to a bunch of
screaming and it's interesting to me
that the head of a monastery I mean
knowing who lived in that castle right
that he would actually put his balls on
the line right in order to send a public
letter saying hey sounds wrong there's
something bad going on over there the
screaming is so loud we can't take it
yeah
this is one of the few things in this
case that kind of give credence to
something bad was happening yeah if you
have people on the clergy trying to
raise the alarm hey man that's not goal
yeah to say that these streets weren't
normal for that time and place that's
that's this day right back what I'm kind
of thinking because you read this book
but what was that book called about the
better angels of our nature by Steven
Pinker they get all into the medieval
mindset about the way people were back
then they would do horrible [ __ ] just
like it was nothing that means that in
my mind the church is trying to raise
the alarm because there's a lot of
screaming going on in there it's
something really because meeting a [ __ ]
beaten one of your service that would
that wouldn't even be noticed back yeah
nobody would have I mean everybody all
did it everybody did they beat each
other yeah yeah see and that's what kind
of leads me to believe like I said I do
think a lot of the more egregious
stories better are probably exaggerated
yeah but I do think she must have been
doing some bad [ __ ] for people to have
even complained yeah
because back then you could if you were
nobility you could basically do whatever
you wanted to a serve right it was
within your authority to punish them and
first of all and and for someone I mean
even though he was in the clergy and
stuff like that and for someone to
publicly come out and complain it
knowing what she could do to you right
you know what I mean it's so it must
have been pretty bad yeah this is 1600s
this is Eastern Europe Eastern Europe
was almost medieval even into the 1900s
there were parts of Russia that looked
like medieval times you know so in the
1600s in that area was pretty rough they
were used to people killing each other
and suffering so for
the alarm it would have been some kind
of extraordinary I would think yeah see
that's kind of where I'm that's where
I'm at this is so that letter like I
said it does kind of cast does make me
think that she's going onto something
okay let's take a break right now and
then we'll come back and talk about I
kind of want to talk about some of the
some of the current people that are
trying to say that she was totally
innocent see that's why that's why he
brought that up yeah I mean that this is
an important clue
yes case I don't think she was totally
innocent like some these people are
saying yeah I don't know I don't like I
said I think a lot of the [ __ ] about her
was probably exaggerated but she must
have done something I thought but anyway
okay so we're gonna take a short break
right now we'll be back in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
okay probably and you know I probably
should have mentioned who's getting one
of the most famous stories about
Elizabeth báthory was that she enjoyed
bathing in the blood of virgins yeah
that she would basically like hang these
girls over the bathtub and drain all
their blood into the tub and she would
be even it because she thought it made
her look younger like she was trying to
retain her you know if they were virgins
oh yeah well she's like well I have to
check you know spray those days a virgin
was about eight years old it's kind of
like the story goes that how she started
doing that was that a servant girl was
brushing her hair and hit a knot and
like pulled her hair a little bit too
hard so Countess báthory whipped around
and punched her in the face and the
girls nose started to bleed and it bled
onto her hand and then when Elizabeth
wiped the blood off she's like hey my
hand looks so young you know to be like
Palmolive like Madge if you guys
remember that commercial no I'm old
well how you would notice one spot on
your hand looking younger than the
surrounding it sounds that sounds very
the legend yes so that story said oh
well she figured hey if it makes this
little spot on my hand look this much
younger that imagine if I sucked in a
whole tub of it yeah so but it should be
noted that the story about bathing in
blood that didn't come out that wasn't
published until 1729 which was more than
a hundred years ago she was dead there
are too many elements to in this sound
like a myth right
and really could you really bathe in
blood I mean without it there's no way
yeah there's not a whole lot of blood in
a human body what is it but two gallon
two gallons maybe something like that
yeah a lot of it not really yeah you
would need to kill a lot of people yeah
and like I said it would start by the
time you drain that that many people to
fill up a tub it would have started to
get sticky and gross yeah I don't think
it's made up so yeah I definitely think
that story was made up because by the
time that story came out about her you
know there was all this other stuff
about vlad the impaler and oh he's a
vampire she's a vampire we're all a
vampire you know what I mean it was kind
of like that type of [ __ ] so I kind of
feel like it kind of got involved with
all the vampire myths that were kind of
coming out around that time also but
some of the lesser things like you know
sewing people's mouths shut
biting them you know taking chunks out
of their flesh you know she would burn
them with pokers and you know stick
pokers up their badges and stuff like
that did she do that maybe that doesn't
sound that crazy and it I mean it sounds
like some of the torture methods that
were around at the time so it wasn't
like she wouldn't have thought of it
right you know if it was happening
though that's the thing was yeah now
like I said rumors started to circulate
her around about her like in the early
1600s like 1602 right around then now
her husband died in 1604 and then the
rumors really started circulating but
really no one did anything until 16 and
the reason that most scholars give for
why suddenly everyone gave a [ __ ] was
that she started a finishing school like
you said at one of her castles allegedly
I don't know if she had gotten to the
point where hey I'm running out of
peasants right it's like no one wants to
come work for me now because they've
heard about it you know or she'd killed
them all but she made the rather
boneheaded move of saying oh well I'm
gonna open up a finishing school like
for girls to come and find out how to be
all fancy and refined and everything
like that and then I'll start killing
those chicks so evidently once she
started going after the daughters of the
landed gentry and other lesser nobility
and stuff like that then suddenly
everything right right there's also a
story that she went
that she went one night to an opera or
to a play or something like that and saw
a woman singing and she was so enchanted
by this woman that she invited the woman
back to the castle
the woman was understandably very
nervous and Countess báthory was like oh
I want you to sing for me the woman was
so nervous that she couldn't sing
because it was Elizabeth báthory she's
like you know but so of course that made
Elizabeth mad and she tortured and
killed the woman sounds like a legend so
that might be a legend too because I
really only saw that in one or two
sources once she started going after
like quote unquote important people that
weren't servants or serfs then people
started to complain now it was 1610
before Palatine Tirtzu who was actually
a friend of her husband's and was kind
of up in all the nobility and everything
like that he was the one that kind of
investigated the whole thing now the
story goes that he went to her castle
with a few other of his men and it was
supposedly a surprise visit he didn't
say he was coming or anything like that
now he says when he got there that they
found nine dead girls in various states
of torture and things that that looks he
says some were burned some of them had
bites taken out of them things like that
I think there were in cages - yeah I
don't know if he said that because I
think the only thing that survives the
trial records do survive like all the
witness accounts against her one of his
letters survives that he wrote to his
wife I don't remember if he specifically
said in that letter that he found girls
in cages but I think he did say that he
found nine dead girls and some that were
dying right like I said some of the
legends said that he caught her in the
act but I don't think that's the case
like the letter doesn't really sound
like that
some also later accounts said that they
came in and it was sue was just bodies
everywhere like she would keep them
under her bed and keep feeding them even
though they were dead and things like
that so yeah so I don't know if that's
true or not but that was another one of
the legends that kind of sprung up about
her what ended up happening
was that tirta was able to round up
they say 300 witnesses that were willing
to say this then the other about what
countess Bathory was up to I don't know
how many of these people had direct
access to the castle like I don't know
how many of them had actually worked
there or had actually been inside it
could just it could just have been
mostly people from around the village
who had heard some [ __ ] I don't know
they conducted investigations and trials
back there I was hokey and it's like
another problem too is that now Countess
báthory was never really put on trial I
mean she was a member of the nobility
she was very very powerful even [ __ ] the
king of Hungary owed her money right you
know what I mean cuz she had more money
than him right so they couldn't really
put her on trial because it was an
embarrassment like you said to all of
the nobility and everything like that
what they ended up doing and I thought
this was funny one of the researchers he
wrote a book I'm glad the Impaler - I
knows mcnally or something like that I'd
have to look it up he said they did what
they called the hors d'oeuvres strategy
where it's like they go after the little
finish because they couldn't get the big
one so who ended up going on trial was
her supposed accomplices were four of
her elder servants it was three older
women and a man I think he was a little
person and these three confessed to
helping her do all these horrible things
however these confessions were extracted
under torture no do we have access to
the actual confessions they are they out
there they're out there I mean I can't
read them right here not in English but
they are out there they're like I said
some of the papers do exist
why don't they cooperate each other I
don't know cuz that would be that'd be
interesting is to actually read them in
their original language yeah and see if
they support one another right because
sometimes you know false confessions are
impossible because there's too many
contradictions but you know I mean you
have four different people each one of
them giving a false confession they
contradict one another right
make certain things if possible yeah you
know I'd love to be I would love to be
able to read was it
archaic Romanian just probably has
written it and you can get your hands on
it you could probably figure it out
although I'm sure countless people and
like I said even some of the
documentaries I saw like they allowed
them like you can't take the papers
obviously because they're valuable but
you can go and look at them so for
people that they tortured and they got
the stories and they said yeah we helped
her do all this horrible stuff two of
the women for sure one they pulled their
either their fingernails or their
fingers off with pincers and then chuck
them onto a fire alive yeah the dwarf
check the people or their people okay
the dwarf guy they were a little nicer
than him they just cut his head off yeah
and then threw him in the fire the
fourth of the fourth lady I'm not
entirely sure what happened to her I
don't know if they killed her too or if
she got off with it or anything like
that I'm gonna be described basically
just old hags well three of them are old
women yeah that she kept around they're
like old peasant hags they would do her
bidding for her yeah so like I said she
never really stood trial she never spoke
in her defense because I you know I
guess you didn't do that back then and
like I said she was super powerful they
so we have to do something to her so
basically what they did was they walled
her up in a room of her own castle and
just house arrest pretty much and they
just left a slit where they could put
food in and stuff like that and she was
in there for almost four years before
she died she was 54 when she done now
before we move on the confessions in the
confessions what did the confession say
about the number of victims and what
happened to them and the motive okay now
I don't know if those particular people
said how many people she killed okay the
commonly thrown around figure of 650
girls comes from another servant a
younger girl and her name was Susanna
they never gave her last name and she
says that countess Bathory had a diary
where she wrote down the names of every
girl that she killed why would she do
that
I don't know yeah it sounds sushi and
she said this servant girl said there
were
150 names in there and that servant girl
was she charged also no she wasn't
charged she was just one of the ones
that victim probably she might have been
yeah it should be noted that this diary
has never been found it seems odd that
if Countess báthory was was indeed doing
all this to all these girls why would
she care what their names were why would
she care about keeping track of them
what you know maybe she would maybe she
would be a blessed serial killer you
know trophies maybe yeah maybe it was so
it's possible that this diary does exist
it's possible that she killed 650 people
I'm kind of doubt it but I don't know I
feel like 650 is too padded number I'm
not saying she didn't kill a [ __ ] ton of
people because she probably did I don't
know if it was 650 though because like I
said that's the only place that that
number comes from is this girl saying oh
she had a book that had 650 names in it
I mean did this girl sit there and count
every single name that way yeah well how
would she have had access to how would
she have had access to it how would she
have known how many names are in there
unless maybe Elizabeth told her that
yeah that's that could be the case we
say Elizabeth actually have seen her
name written it's actually a bit well
yeah well Elizabeth is just the
anglicized version yeah of earth Sabet
yeah that's her actual name okay so the
problem being like I said after she was
walled up after she died
apparently her crimes and things like
that were so embarrassing that they
tried to erase her from history they did
not entirely succeed obviously and her
name still kind of resonated and all
these legends started to spring up
springing up about her which is why no
one can really figure out what she did
now in recent years and it's not just
Hungarians either Oh some apologists
have sprung up who are trying to
basically insist that countess Bathory
was entirely innocent
or that she was framed or set up try to
get her wealth right now there is some
evidence to support that because things
like that did happen yes big things like
that did happen and they're saying you
know this was still an age of witch
hunts yeah women who were widowed
particularly powerful women who had a
lot of power and land and money they
were targets because they were seen
since there were women without husbands
that you're seen as vulnerable so you
know people want them getting they
didn't want to get woman getting out of
hand right so there was you know kind of
a precedent for you know males doing
some kind of machinations like around
them where they would like make up story
where she's a witch or something like
that or something like that so they
could get her [ __ ] now it should be
noted that after she died all of her
property and wealth and stuff like that
was broken up between various relatives
and stuff like that who had kind of
conspired with you know with terzo and
there is some evidence that Tirzah the
guy that went after was kind of planning
to go after her before all the hubbub
started like there are little hints and
some letters that he wrote like a couple
years before the charges were brought
that sort of could be read to say that
he was gonna think of some yeah I
thought this is bring her down I thought
about this but you know what if she was
guilty the same thing would have
happened right it's hard to tell
yeah if she was innocent they would have
framed her but if she was guilty they
still would've took all her stuff - yes
because they took all her stuff doesn't
mean and that is exactly the next point
I was gonna make it's like maybe I mean
the fact that she seemed like she was
kind of a psychopath yeah maybe that
just helped them it made it easier for
them because there was already like I
said there was already stories
circulating about her many many years
before anything was done I think that's
more likely because remember the church
was trying to the clergy was trying to
raise warning about her yes screaming
you know that was happening in there I
think she was psycho yeah it's a real
abusive you know it's sadistic
they wanted her [ __ ] and they made sure
they got and they made sure they got it
and like I said she almost kind of
inadvertently helps them out right by
giving him by giving them an excuse to
go after her so he probably blew a lot
of what she did on proportion right but
I guarantee you she was tortured people
under the old kind of medieval standards
which that'd be pretty bad yeah what
they did to people back then like I said
they pull her fingers off with hot
pincers and chip during right
questioning yeah like the torture they
did during her trial ironically yeah
what's just as bad [ __ ] said she was
doing yeah but I guess they didn't
really bet the register now the question
is whether was she a serial killer and
then here's the weird thing
what makes the forces that create a
serial killer today I don't think the
littles actually existed back then what
creates a serial killer today it's
mostly men and a society has to be a
certain way to create a serial killer
and I think it was so primitive back
then I don't think I don't think it
would manifest itself in the same way I
think it was way she's almost kind of
like she's really one of the if she did
do everything they said she was almost
kind of like one of the earliest like
modern type serial killers it's like if
sex was the motive it has to be a sexual
motive to the Azzurri I think it might
have been find good I think it might
have been good man now it should be
noted that this though this is this like
basically medieval BDSM you know is that
honest with you like some of the charges
levied against her do sound very much
like that it was with only with
unwilling participants yeah but
punishing people beneath you was one of
their responsibilities they were
supposed to do that yeah to keep him in
line because they were the law of the
land literally they were judge jury and
executioner so they had to dole out
punishment too right people who did
wrong or messed up but maybe it gets to
a point where you start enjoying doling
out that that's what I think they are
just killing up and you
I'm a real [ __ ] sadistic psycho
that's probably what happened because
like I said when my husband was alive
you know they did kind of have a
reputation for beating up their servants
and everything like that they had a
reputation for being strict but nothing
crazy like nothing that would cause
people to be like [ __ ] that I'm not
working in that castle yeah you know
what I mean so it was overly strict but
not unusual for the time it just it
really seems like once her husband died
and her husband kind of seemed to get
off on it too a little bit
yeah you know as little as we know about
him you know he wasn't really um
vilified for that because it was a man
and that's just what they did I feel
like and I've seen a couple other
scholars point this out you know they
said that the stories about her bathing
in virgin blood and bloody blood that
came out later they said those stories
might have come out not only in the
absence of any actual evidence about
what she did but also because it was
very hard for people back then to
picture a woman as a sexual sadist yeah
so they said they had to give her some
reason it was her vanity that she had to
bathe in blood so she could keep young
like she had to have a reason for
killing all these people it couldn't
just be because she got off on it right
yeah because they said old women aren't
like that that concept of getting off on
doing something in those days maybe not
well that's another thing that's kind of
hard to because we're kind of taking our
modern sense of rides and trying to
force it back on people who might who
might not think I mean they obviously
didn't think the same way sixteen
hundred's is not the medieval period no
but in Eastern Europe it was still the
media it was basically medieval Society
yeah the mentality was not enlightened
right they were mean and even even in
the West you know the British royal
family they were recorded his doing some
pretty bad [ __ ] right to each other they
would kill their own family members and
bury the kids inside it's almost like it
wasn't really accepted that's not really
the right word but it was expected I
guess it's more like if people didn't or
maybe like well [ __ ] happens I'd only be
it seemed like that well like it wasn't
good but they didn't really do much of
anything about it you don't want to take
these royal families and you know put
them too much on a pedestal I mean these
are basically crime families basically
and particularly so back then yeah
they're like the drug cartels yeah I
mean going back to what you were saying
before about that maybe not having a
concept of serial killers or mayor them
the culture not really creating serial
killers it kind of it should be noted
there are precedents and her family a
few of her relatives cuz like I said she
had a lot of relatives that were princes
and kings and things like that
there was some madness that ran in her
family christian breeding had happened a
lot in royal families and also there is
a story that the way she was brought up
might have contributed I mean there's a
very famous story about her going around
that when she was 6 years old because
her father who was supposedly kind of a
badass who tortured beat people and
stuff like that
that when she was 6 years old her father
took her and showed her a gypsy who had
I don't know if he had poached on their
land or get stolen something or
something like that and her dad had the
Gypsy sewn into the belly of a dying
horse what and just left
both the horse and the gypsy there and
it took them a while to die and he kept
bringing Elizabeth back every day and
saying like this is what happens it's
true
if it's true that's like I said it could
be an apocryphal story but apparently
that kind of [ __ ] was very common so if
she'd have seen that when she was 6
years old she was already kind of
inclined toward that sort of yeah then
maybe yeah sure she could have grown up
yes had no concept of psychology here
and the effect you know I mean cycle
effects of things they just weren't like
that you know that's why I don't even
think that they really had a concept of
I'm gonna do this and get off on it
I think the each one of them lived in
their own little internal world yeah I
mean and they probably didn't really
didn't seem to be the kind of people
that discussed their feelings and their
motives for doing things so they
probably thought that the only they did
that kind of
yes they because everything was done in
kind of like a the church was very
powerful so everything was kind of like
painted with in a religious tone you
know talking about yeah now I'm kind of
curious there most of someone the most
complicated books was the Bible there's
really not a whole lot to the Bible yeah
I don't think they really understood the
world in reality too well well you
didn't really I mean it wasn't like now
where you know you can travel very
easily and you can read whatever you
want to read online but yeah it was so
maybe like you said maybe people were
more they were animalistic I'm pretty
sure yeah so I wonder if it would have
occurred to her that what she was doing
was bad or if she had just been I mean
the environment she was raised in she
had so much money and power and said
like that that she could pretty much do
whatever she wanted to and actually you
know as long as she was killing the
serpent girls no one did anything about
it so she probably just thought whatever
she probably didn't think it was bad at
all she just thought well I like it so
yeah and maybe didn't even really
question why she was being gratified by
this maybe she didn't yeah that that's a
modern concept yeah gratification I
don't think I mean I I definitely think
cuz I just saw her doing her duty yeah
yeah this is not supposed to do yeah
maybe I'm like I said no one's stopping
her right not like you know is there
value and maybe looking at her story and
trying to psychoanalyze her sure I mean
it's interesting we're never gonna know
cuz she's long dead obviously like what
what she would have thought of her
motives are she even thought about it if
she just did it because it was something
she enjoyed and no one stopped her well
here's nothing knows that she evidently
according to the investigators made
temps to kind of hide it a little bit at
least from other Nobles what she was
trailing behind her walls yeah wasn't
like the bodies were she'll never knew
the bodies were just there to be seen to
a lot of them she did bury them yeah but
I heard like I said and it's
hard to know like how much does legend
and how much is not I think at first she
did try to bury them around the castle
and then like the story go is that there
were eventually so many bites she was
like running out of room and so she took
to just kind of like throwing him out
the windows which I don't know
yeah so it's like I don't know how true
a lot of that is because I mean as big
as her castles are and some of them
still stand at least the ruins of this
and you know you can see pictures of me
googling but maybe they were just used
two dead bodies being around everything
stinking and everything like that but it
really does seem weird that she would
just kind of like leave bodies laying
around if you look at them you maybe if
she did them if you look at the
paintings of her actual paintings that
were from those yeah from her time she
looked like a little bitty woman she did
she didn't look like a I mean there is a
portion of her I'll put one that was
painted in 1585 I believe now some of
the ones that are supposed to be of her
they're not sure if they're of her
because you know at this point it's hard
ro but this one that was painted in 1585
they said that's probably her because
they other portraits of other Habsburg
family wears people who are related to
her they said you know that's a very
distinctive nose and the distinctive
ears and stuff like that so that is
probably her but now some of the
portraits that they don't they're not
sure if it's her not one that I saw
she's kind of had a little heart-shaped
face yeah with like I said I think
little ears yeah big brown eyes and she
just she has kind of a big long nose I
mean it's not really well she's not
really well drawn yeah actually the 1585
portrait it's not a great for not really
but it looks like they're trying to
paint someone who's you know five feet
tall maybe it looks like a little bitty
person yeah and I mean I should note too
that I mean despite all the [ __ ] about
her she was actually able to marry off
her daughters I mean because I didn't
mention that she had kids four of them
some people think maybe she had a fifth
one when she was a kid that nobody knew
about like that was kind of a bastard
and stuff but I don't know if that's not
really verified but she had four for
sure
she was able to marry her two daughters
off very successfully like two others so
it wasn't like other noble families were
like get away from me you know what I
mean I don't know it doesn't really seem
like she was super vilified in the
nobility
even but maybe she married the daughters
off and she was apparently a super good
mother hmm I mean apparently she loved
the [ __ ] out of her kids they still have
some letters of hers where she talks
about her kids and apparently she was
super into him and she well they had
serial killers that were super into and
yeah that's the thing it's like you know
Hitler loved his dog so you know that
doesn't really say anything now a few
letters of hers that do survive I don't
believe she mentions anything about hey
murdered some servant girls their
location why would you put that my
letter really but the tone of her
letters does seem like someone who is
very um take no [ __ ]
she's very no nonsense this is the way
it's gonna be involve us you know she
was she was very much like that she
wasn't she ran a big huge Empire you
know what that could lend some cringe to
the other story that she was set up
could be that she was she was one of the
richest people around she's more rich
richer than the king yeah and maybe she
was pretty smart and she's starting to
getting too powerful and had to take her
out and maybe they just she was abusive
towards her servants so use that as an
excuse maybe the abuse wasn't as bad as
they said see ya that is a possibility
I'm not saying that she wasn't might
have been just standard punishment for
the time right which it's not good but I
mean it wasn't unusual for the time
maybe she just beat the [ __ ] I ever
servants like everyone else I do a nail
stick right but the fact that and if she
was disliked in the villages excuse me
then I mean I don't think they would
have had a hard time drumming up
peasants from the village who wanted to
kind of take her out because they didn't
like her right you know cuz maybe she
was kind of a [ __ ] on the other hand I
should say that there are still existing
church records from the area's at that
time that do show an unusual amount of
young girls dying okay in the area
because here's that whether they died of
natural causes or whether she was just
taking them right there were you know
there were rumors that she was
kidnapping the girls or luring them
there with work or with her school or
whatever and then taking this man yes
she must have been now the silliest
thing and I should mention this before
we end the show the silliest thing that
I've heard from people that think that
she was completely innocent which I do
not buy like I said I can buy that maybe
people exaggerated things to get her
[ __ ] and things like that that's totally
plausible do I think she was totally
innocent hell no you know she probably
did enough horrible [ __ ] that you don't
have to exaggerate [ __ ] but some people
have gone so far as to say oh well all
the girls that died in the area are all
the dead girls that they found when they
came to investigate they either died of
natural causes or they died because
Elizabeth was trying to help them like
they're trying to paint her as some kind
of like a wise woman like she knew
healing practices and stuff like that
like I saw one guy who who thinks she
didn't do anything and he pointed out
that this one implement that is usually
portrayed as heard using it to like burn
girls like in a torture kind of fashion
he said well this implement is was
actually used to cauterize wounds it
wasn't you know I mean so it's like it's
possible that she could have been trying
to help them like they had a wound or
something like that but the thing is
there's just so many there were so many
other rumors circulating but there's
just had to be something to it
right I mean like he said particularly
from that time period when everyone was
violent everyone was beating their
servants everybody was doing that kind
of thing for all these rumors start
circulating about her in particular no
she must have been doing something above
and beyond what was normal for the time
that's kind of how I feel about it
according to the things that you told me
in that book about the medieval period
no with the mentality of the time these
are the kind of people that would walk
down the street with you and they'd see
like a dead cat they'd pick it up sniff
it take a dump wherever they were at the
time and they were dirty and they were
like feral people that kind of that's
fan of like people nowadays that like
taste something that's gone bad and
they're like hey this has gone bad here
taste it and I think the reason why I
think the reason why nobility
cruel to them is because serfs in the
lower classes they were probably damn
near feral
they were probably pretty bad too well
everyone kind of said that back then
yeah well like I said you know Elizabeth
báthory did you know I a lot of the
stuff about her it's probably
exaggerated but I think she probably did
kill did she kill six six hundred and
fifty girls I don't know nothing you'd
remember that these Nobles were not
enlightened people if you were to meet
them today they just would have been
dirtbags yeah by today's standards
peasants probably savages it was really
not a time I would know you don't want
to add to that a time machine if I ever
invented one when you think of medieval
periods and you know Renaissance time
1600s well that's kind of confusing
because it wasn't uniform Europe was
different you know Western Europe
Eastern Europe everything was different
but it wasn't what he saw it at
Disneyland and magic castles and
princesses they weren't like that
well even like a rent fest or anything
like this but it's fun to dress up like
that and you know now that we have
modern sensibilities and modern hygiene
and things of that nature but yeah those
how these people's brains developed back
then in that environment in that culture
with that little knowledge that they had
plus I feel like a lot of their brains
were probably pickled because then they
start drinking alcohol with stuff yeah
yeah they're all like riddled with pox
yes like that like I don't think I would
want to go back to that time period yeah
and I said yeah even the rich ones yeah
yeah
and didn't bathe well no sorry they
didn't bay they didn't have toys in
flush toilet you're grossing yourself
out
see that was your fault bedtime that was
your fault all right so that's our
rambling discussion about Elizabeth did
we got anything anything you told them
how she died
water up okay yeah yeah they water up
but she didn't die of starvation I think
she just got sick and died yeah she just
got sick and then they I don't even know
if they know what it was that killed her
um the story goes that the jailer came
one night to bring her food and she said
oh I'm really cold or something like
that and then they came the next day and
she was laying there dead facedown so
she just died of some disease she was
all like 54 but you know she back in
those yes she um she'd been in there
almost four years in that one know that
room was probably pretty big you know
the living situation back then wasn't
that great anyway so yeah there to go
probably wasn't that big a deal she's
like oh just sending this wrong room
okay yes not like you're gonna have the
club right what do you mean I can't
yeah but if you like the show please
like subscribe also go subscribe to our
13 o'clock in minutes channel if you
would and also check out our patreon at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast
there's a bunch of cool extra [ __ ] on
there you can get if you support us and
we also have t-shirts at wwsz Elcom
slash 13 o'clock we still have the five
designs if you want to check one of
those out and go follow us on twitter
and go like our Facebook page and I
think that'll do it for episode 53 see
you next Tuesday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see her John
you
[Music]
you